recently one of the most unique
streamers twitch has
ever seen exploded in popularity
code miko a final fantasy inspired v
tuber
controlled by a woman who goes by the
name the technician
but this unique streaming style has come
at a cost
see miko has been banned from twitch
three
times and finally we know why
hello fellow kids it is that time where
i ask you to
scroll down and hit that subscribe
button while you're at it you might as
well hit that notification bell so you
never
miss a new video now if the technician
doesn't have you going oh damn tell me
more
her awkward in a good way interviews
with some of twitch's biggest stars
are equally as strange but awesome and
on january 19th
mikko was banned from twitch for a third
time
and as you guys probably know with
twitch it's usually three strikes in
your out
banned gone for good and because the
internet are a bunch of coomers people
were speculating for
a while anyway that she got banned
because she used the word simp
on stream which if you didn't know has
been banned by twitch
well you can't say the word anymore is
that true
the i can't say the word ship wait we
can't say the word symphony
let the water seep anymore
wait really starting in january
wait what oh my god i am
so but she was quick to dispel this
rumor and on january 23rd she posted a
twit longer
explaining the real reason why she was
banned quote during an
interview a female streamer and i were
talking about female harassment online
and i asked her what was the worst
comment she had ever received
when i saw the email it was pretty bad
and it was more like a threat
than a comment from my experience
threats are almost never
sent from a user's actual email address
but
throwing up the screenshot got me banned
now i talked to mikko and what was one
of the most
entertaining interviews i've ever done
and here's what she had to say about
that january ban
it just didn't come across the fact that
oh hey you know
this person like there is like first and
last name
email on here um you know
like don't show it right so it was like
my mistake
um i honestly didn't
realize until it was too late but she
was also banned twice before
both back in september so what happened
well she says both bands were due to
let's just call it inappropriate attire
i got banned after this stream for an
inappropriate attire
oh what okay all right
so what is that exactly um
it's a stinky dobby call
very very naughty yeah i can see why
twitch maybe thought that was a bit of a
problem
what is this thing talking about giant
dildos with youtuber moist critical
or having pokemane yell simp over and
over and over again
some symptoms of symptoms
and i mean if anything goes wrong at
least it's your channel not mine
well since september mikko has slowly
gained a following on twitch
before exploding in december snagging
over 200
000 followers in the span of a month and
it's easy to see why
her content is tailor-made for the clip
that [ __ ] mentality that reddit loves
and honestly it's the kind of [ __ ] that
has twitch staff scrambling for their
terms of service documents
here i'll drink with you
mikko's thing is interviewing other
streamers obviously she does
more than that but her rise on twitch
and youtube is due in large part to
interviewing people like hassan
skara and ludwig and while originally a
lot of people saw her as
that half-naked robot who keeps getting
banned for not wearing a lot of clothes
those interviews became insanely popular
did anyone tell you that you're kind of
intimidating
all the time it's my bulging muscularity
and just absolutely
disgusting stature i'm standing at a
beautiful five
foot six like going through doorways is
oftentimes burning some it's just
massive shoulders popping through are
you only five foot six
did you say only did i hear that
it's cute i wanted to get a better sense
of what
miko is because some people refer to her
as a v
tuber hassan thought she was an ai bot
for a portion of his interview
so i asked her well she wanted to create
a game character because she had this
idea of a game character being able to
travel through different game worlds and
if
i can do that then she has an excuse to
try to create different types different
genres of games right um
so she made me into an
npc that basically
i'm a failed video game character and so
i'm
streaming on twitch on top of being a
failed video game character miko is a v
tuber model controlled by the technician
and the technician
literally brought her to life using a
combination of body and face tracking
software
it also happens to be an extremely
ominous nickname and v-tubing if you
didn't know is a type of animation
technology that's been pretty popular
for years now
especially in japan we covered the
v-tuber explosion just a few months ago
similar to pokemane using her v-tuber
model when she
just doesn't want to appear on camera
it's not uncommon for people to use
v-tubing as a way to take the pressure
or
sometimes objectifying nature of
streaming off of them
while also creating work that they
typically wouldn't make
now v tubing has always had an element
of interactivity to it
whether it's chat trying to teach a
vtuber internet slang or
the model being able to change outfits
and expressions but what sets miko apart
is just how interactive her streams are
and how she's able to turn
that into some truly absurd moments of
streaming gold
is that me this is hassan hello
how are you buddy
looking great yeah chad made me this
they say look like you wait can i see
your dumpy
after serving out her first two bands in
september mikko returned to streaming in
a big way
because in december the technician was
finally revealed on stream hello
everyone
so this is mikko
i'm technician hi nice to meet you
after that the technician herself gained
a bunch of popularity
and began joining mikko at the end of
her streams
to you know just hang out with chad and
answer questions
there was even a time when she got
trolled by chat when
she tried to prove that she had a
boyfriend brandon
i says tell chat that you're real
and you're not and
yes i am a real boyfriend
branded now mikko says that this twitch
adventure
she and the technician have been on is
almost like this happy accident
she had an interest in 3d animation
initially and then she got into
vr and then from there
she got into research and development
within vr
space and that's when she researched and
developed specifically
virtual production which is like virtual
live animation like this
um and then that was like her career
um she always liked twitch and when she
got laid off
from her work basically she put two to
two together
and decided to create me and you might
be wondering what miko and the
technician have been up to since her
band in january
well it turns out creating some cool
[ __ ] apparently
the technician has really aggressive
plans when it comes to
um you know future interactions and
future games and stuff for the february
of this return
it's gonna be like a small
uh what's the word like a small preview
of that
um so there will be some new chat
interrupt
integration um there's gonna be
an upgrade with my interview format
there's gonna be a
game show at the end so it's there's
it's fun just lots of fun
miko is exactly the type of streamer
twitch
thinks it wants the only problem in
mikko's case is
by constantly throwing new content at
the wall
she ran right into twitch's murky is all
hell tos
and she got banned what the hell do you
do with a fake human being dressed as a
racy nun
on stream what do you do about a v tuber
model that can change her appearance at
literally any time
and is often subjected to the perverted
whims of her chat
do the rules still apply to her
essentially mikko and the technician
have taken two staples of twitch culture
the just chatting interview and
interaction with chat combined it with a
growing trend
at least for the platform and created
something that
honestly could only ever exist on twitch
her content is tailor-made for the clip
that [ __ ] meant
no why the did i go into a mid-2000s
in radio dj voice after serving out her
two bands up some
after serving out her two bands in
september
after serving out her two bands in
september in
september in september
pronounce it that way